hey it's another video that no one asked
for and it's completely irrelevant and
not topical anymore blame or should I
say Balam excuse me it's pronounced
Balaam after the sound of the gun no one
gives a [ __ ] shut up but the movie came
out and I make movie reviews right now
that's right I made a video talking
about my favourite manga blam blam [ __ ]
so I'm gonna try and not repeat too much
of what I said but basically there's
another anime movie adaptation
I don't Netflix Thank You Nick Thank You
Netflix for making me embarrassed for
liking my favorite piece of art and also
Thank You Netflix for making what was
already a mess of adaptations into it
even further so we have blam the
original and we have blam and so on
which is like well I guess we explain a
little bit more we didn't tell you that
much did we and then we have a blam the
anime which people really view as
something in high regards just as this
review I have never rated anything 1 out
of 10 until I encountered but great do
you see what I'm going here is it's
already so confusing what blam is
because there's already these different
adaptations everywhere that are so
goddamn bad when the original one is a
masterpiece
we have blam the prologue what in the
[ __ ] is I never even heard of this and
then we have blam the special what and
that's pretty much it just kidding
there's also the prequel which is
actually pretty good the peak was
alright and now thank you
we have blam the shitty movie just
kidding
we also have blam dinky Rio she kick in
cash so - shoot soo sach Hussein which
is a remake and apparently the movies
made as an adaptation of the remake what
didn't the what is what why ah oh and
also did I mention they all share the
same universe as other animes like
Knights of Cydonia now this is not
compute
at all it's even confusing why this
movie exists to begin with because vayam
is not very popular it was written in
1994 it's it's the kind of thing where
either you love it or you hate it and
those kind of things doesn't really
translate well into into it other
adaptations at least it doesn't have a
good track record of it the reason why
it's a movie is because Netflix owned
the original series of night of Cydonia
which was made by the same creator as
bland eight Knights of Cydonia don't get
me wrong it's not bad but it's basically
I don't want to be too harsh but it's
basically the salad version of lamb it's
not a bad anime by any means but if you
compare the two of them it's goddamn
awful if I compare them I would say
integrity and no integrity it's like how
can we make something really really
popular
okay well let's have what's popular oh
yeah mecha okay what else do people like
they like to see sexy underwear and
boobies okay that's that and okay I
don't know how to explain it okay the
story of bland the simple synopsis took
me so goddamn long to figure out it was
you're you're thrown into this universe
in the manga and you have to figure out
yourself what is going on what the heck
is happening and understanding but the
movie starts and it just tells you
nobody really knows when the world
became this way the contagion suddenly
started and humans lost the power to
connect with the city the city continued
to expand on its own in humans
we're seen as illegal residents and
exterminated it's like if you worked
your whole day to get an ice-cream and
then all the sudden everyone just gets
ice creams for free that's how I would
kiss a terrible way to compare obviously
they have to explain what is happening
it's a one-hour 46 minute movie Betty I
don't know just watching it I'm not the
main plot of blame is that the guy needs
to find net terminal genes so he can
connect to the net sphere that which
will shut down
all the robots that has been ruining the
planet for years and just kept building
and building and building and fighting
against them the next fear is sort of
like a reincarnation of the Internet in
a in a futuristic way the main reason I
find them to be it such a masterpiece is
because it doesn't try and tell you a
story it puts you in the universe and
you're you are left to figure it out
yourself now admittedly the writer had
so moany hey isn't a good storyteller
and he's basically just avoiding
explaining anything there's very little
logic behind anything and it sort of
makes it open for interpretation you see
this in a lot of movies and stories
where it's so vague that you have to
fill it in yourself and it almost makes
it like I feel like it's a basic human
instinct that if we were not told
everything of something we want to fill
that ourselves we fill it with what we
think makes sense and therefore we value
it higher than what it is which might
make you question was it even that great
to begin with then but let's not talk
about that now blam takes place in such
a long time that time becomes irrelevant
if you look at the whole universe ok
let's say this is the time of the
universe and this is the time we've
existed as human beings ok what if we
stretched out that time super duper long
huh then you can tell a story during a
small period and then jump ahead and it
wouldn't really make that much of a
difference as opposed to if you'd have
it this much and then like we are now
this is making me sense oh my god right
I'm no Neil deGrasse Tyson okay but so
if you have like a really small time and
then you jump a lot you will be like
whoa what happened here but since we
have such a long amount of time passing
we can
it makes time irrelevant and there's
such a long time placing going through
the anime and there's so many different
events and different interesting things
that you could make the movie out of
what did they pick the movie to make
about this goddamn fisherman village why
the heck would you make it about these
fishermen it doesn't make any sense at
all it's the most uninteresting piece of
the whole universe I don't care about
those people who the heck are they I
don't even know what about making it
when he meets Dumbo Chomsky what about
when Devine try to enter the net sphere
anything would be goddamn more important
than this stupid fisherman now a lot of
people criticize the this type of movie
because of the CGI is made by polygon
pictures and I really like this type of
style I think it looks great in Knights
of Cydonia it just doesn't fit blam
because Byam it's so grungy and the
style is so heavy but here it's the sort
of way too plain I really think I would
have preferred to see this in a
traditional drawn anime style even
though typically I I'm not opposed to
CGI in anime which probably most people
don't agree with look how neat and
polished it looks compared to like the
manga it just falls so flat a classic a
reoccurring theme that I find with a lot
of re remakes and reallocation is that
they don't seem to understand what may
good there's this bit where she takes
off her helmet for Achille the main
character and oh there you go cute
little blushy
blushing cheeks oh look at that little
tears in her eyes so dramatic
oh she's blushing for kilee oh that's so
cute
no no it's [ __ ] not it's not cute
lamb has absolutely no Romans in it and
it's an adult manga that doesn't go
overboard with the gore and there's no
sexual tension or a reference I sort it
there's no as much as a lot of anime
tits there's none of it in blam but then
you go and have like
some romance aspects of this and it's
just kind of like why why would you why
this is reach Ange this video to angry
sweet Brent's about animate is so stupid
I don't know why I even care but it just
it's like if you're gonna make a remake
at least respect and understand what
made the original good ok major spoiler
coming up just what look away the way
they introduced her is here they show
her right away the introduction of key
boys one of my favorite parts our
favorite introduction of any character
in any anime ain't any manga here they
introduced her they show her right away
beautiful oh look I'm Kiba oh great
now we know this is how Kira is
introduced in the manga ok she's this
disgusting thing that he founds in the
sewer and she's and you didn't even know
the gender but basically she's like oh
I've been here for a long time III need
your help I promise I'm a big deal ok
I've been here for a thousand for
thousands of years yeah I can help you
out if you help me out ok I promise I'm
a big deal I'm a scientist
ok I'm a scholar in the most perfect
moment keyboa pierce and bam she's a
strong independent woman ok she's got
her own body back again and look at that
super cool and you're like whoa she's
actually not a disgusting homeless
person and his dope it's dope to find
that out but here they're like oh I'm
Kibo oh great now from this point onward
I'm pretty lost in the movie they
basically reduced the story from we need
to save humanity - these people need
some food because they are hungry
it's about to break down the
gravitational beam emitter and you're
like hella yeah the most powerful weapon
in the universe
it's basically they're the gun version
of the one punch man this thing will
blow through anything that's the point
of the gun it's a huge part of the story
it's almost like a character on its own
the blame is not blamed without the gun
it's even in the name you know this
thing will WAIS through anything that's
why it's so cool oh I can't wait for him
to finally shoot that [ __ ] I'll never
mind she can just block it what are you
amazed she can block it what you ruined
it you ruined it you ruined it for me I
don't get it the thing about the gun is
that it can pull it through anything
that's how he gets past certain levels
in the manga you can't just stop you
can't just you can't just do that
the reason why I love blames so much is
because it's not your traditional sci-fi
it doesn't have all the spaceship flying
into space all that's Hollywood sci-fi
[ __ ] it has this raw take over this
dystopian future and it doesn't just try
and tell a story it even brings in
philosophical thoughts and I always saw
that as a merge of reality internet and
religion sort of into one idea that in
the future in blame you have the net
sphere which is basically like
reincarnation of the Internet in a
futuristic set and it sort of blends the
idea of religion and Internet in a
really funny and weird way what if we
created our own heaven you know and
because all the bad guys try to sneak
into the net sphere and that's sort of
their goal and the rest of the people
outside of the next weird tries to
connect to it as well but they lot long
lost access to it so it almost like we
turned ourselves the planet our own
planet into hell and we made our own
heaven which is the next where the
internet connecting to the internet I
don't know this is how I interpret it
and I'm sure most people probably
wouldn't even be like what the [ __ ] are
you're saying but that's
what I really like about them is that
you can it's open for interpretation and
it's fun to do that read the manga it's
really great and I'll stop talking about
blam now thank you for listening to my
angry anime rent and leave a like if you
enjoyed really appreciate it
remember to subscribe and swap them out